the gyro gun experience so how long did
this that mean how long did you sit on
this story how long did you know about
this and how what was the process of
having this sort of build in your mind
the point where you wanted to write it
direct and produce it cast it honestly I
read the book exactly 20 years ago I
read it in the fall of 99 when I was
when Fight Club came out that's right
around the time as I read this novel
motherless Brooklyn but but the novels
about the torretta detective who's
trying to solve the murder of his his
only friend basically but it takes place
in the 90s it's not about any of that
stuff about New York in the 50s or
anything it's just and the character is
just amazing though
like amazing so when I read it the hook
was the character I was like I was like
what a great character it's so it's such
a wild he's like I just this hot mess of
of he's smart but he's totally messed up
he's he's funny but also really it's
pretty painful and lonely and it was
just everything and I was like that's I
get so into trying to figure that out
for reasons that are a little hard to
explain the tone of the book feels like
a 50s detective novel but it's set in
the modern world and I was afraid in a
movie that would feel a little bit like
The Blues Brothers
like guys in fedoras but a Prius is sort
of like mmm maybe this would just be
cooler if we said it in the 50s and I
talked to the author about that and he
was super into those movies and so he
said okay Wow
so then then but then the middle period
was the period of mashing that up with
the with these sort of stories the New
York Chinatown kind of of it the the
deep dark history of what really went on
in New York and that took a long time
and then I I had it ready in 2012 I was
really ready to dig go and I just
couldn't get it to guy couldn't get
Bruce was head he was in and that was
kind of good but I couldn't get everyone
I wanted together at the same
and I couldn't get him the amount of
money I needed or that I thought I
wanted and I couldn't get a studio to
back it because honestly you know number
one like I'm not like you know I'm not
like a green light anything he does kind
of an actor that's it's just you know I
think that's a that's a different sort
of thing but also I was out there saying
it's sort of like Rain Man meets LA
Confidential and people's eyes just kind
of cross they're like they're like bring
us the next one like they're like we
don't get it we don't get it
wait if we don't get yet it's like and
also I got like I had like this idea of
getting I love Radiohead and I like jazz
and I wanted to like I got Thom Yorke to
write a song for the film but I got
Wynton Marsalis to do all the jazz and
stuff and people were also they were
like this is these things are not gonna
go well together you know and then they
went to get like a lot of people have
said to me which is not it's not me
taking a lot of people said to me it's
the best music in a film that they've
heard in many many years flea flea
played trumpet and um and base on Thom
Yorke's track in the film and and fleet
you know fleas like a really good
trumpet player and his dad was a jazz
musician and I didn't know that flea
came out of the movie like crying he was
like that's honestly my favorite music
that I've ever heard in a home and I
think and and and but you can't you
can't tell people that you you I thought
that would work I thought this mashup
would work because I knew Tom and I knew
he loves Charles Mingus and and I knew
wenton was capable of doing he's really
interested in dissonant weird edgier
kind of modernist music as well and I
was like this is gonna work and it and
it did it's it's really the music's
amazing in the film it it's like its own
like the wreck the records out now and
people are flipping out about that just
the music and the movie hasn't even come
out yet
with such a crazy combination of factors
and details that you smashed all
together yeah and it's got to feel first
of all it's got to be a tremendous
relief and also feel amazing that it's
you did it I do feel that I feel like it
would have haunted me and I it was
rattling around in my head such a long
time I felt very discouraged about it at
times that's kind of like you know I've
done a few okay things like I've done
some stuff that was weird and that
people didn't understand and it's it's
come together pretty great you know what
I mean and and uh you sort of go god I
never I never expect anybody to give me
money to make something like that's
that's just risky like I would never put
money into making movies never like it's
too risky you know and I get it so I'm
not like I deserve this like right but
it was more like I sometimes I was just
like am I gonna be able to figure this
out or not am I am I gonna get this done
and uh and I think getting it done and
having it not having quit on it and in
some ways feeling not actually knowing
that it's better that I made it now I
know more I was more if I'd tried to do
it 20 years ago I couldn't I didn't have
the chops to do some of the thing I
liked working with Spike Lee and
Alejandro and you really when people
like that really like it up to my sense
of how to do I learned a lot about how
to do a big thing with out all the money
in the world now this is release
nationwide worldwide like when it's
released on this Friday right yeah this
Friday
it's everywhere yes sir tomorrow brought
America yet yeah it's a it's a wide
release here
I hope yeah and I think honestly like
the day it comes out like you can either
see Terminator like not at 9.11
or or ours there's like not and I I like
certify on the Joe Rogan experience like
there's not a grown up human being who
will not
be stoked about this film like I can say
that people who are seeing it
are very very very into it and very
bought in because it is one of those
like it's a it's a big meal but it's a
really like it's a really rich good meal
and it has amazing amazing performances
I don't think Alec Baldwin has ever been
better in a movie
honestly and I think Willem Dafoe is
amazing
Michael Kate Williams is amazing and the
music is great and and it's a it's a
cool story and I think um I think it's
kind of one of those things that it's
worth going to the theater to see but I
guarantee you it's more worth your time
than another terminator well it sounds
like it to me
I'm really excited about it and I will
see it
[Applause]